I guess what I'm trying to say. Okay. Sorry.
Hello.
Oh my gosh. It's happening.
A second high school has now closed truth schools. We opened first.
You can't have one basic answer across the country because we have so many,
much variability. It can not be done unsafely,
or we'll be right back where we started. I've just feel like that's the risk.
Some of us seniors are willing to take, to have our senior year.
My name is Charlie. I'm going into my seat.
And I'm from Los Angeles, California. My name is NILAH. I live in Philadelphia,
Pennsylvania, and I am going to meet. Hi. My name is [inaudible]
. I'm from the greater Boston area, Massachusetts, and I'm going to be a sophomore. I'm
Sophie
. I live in Omaha, Nebraska, and I'm going to be a sophomore in high school. My name's Jacob.
I live in Michigan. I'm
going into my junior high and Vanessa, I am 70 years. So, and I live in Florida. I'm Hannah. I'm going into my senior year and I'm in Spokane, Washington.
Tech-Talk is life three, two, one.
I used to spend so much time on Tik TOK,
but it got to a point where it became a problem.
I sometimes spent four hours on Tik TOK, just like scrolling.
For me. It's like clearly a problem, but I see like roll with it.
Like the enjoyment that I get out of tech talk is like, so immense, like,
I don't know what I do with my six extra hours.
I never even like got Tik TOK or had Tik talk.
I just don't really get it. Honestly.
It really depends on like what content you watch. Once you get past the skinny,
hot girls dancing, like commentary, teak talk.
I mean, those tech talks end up everywhere. And those references slip in.
It's definitely not something that you can ignore because it's so there.
My school to go back to in-person learning
three, two, one,
And if one of the worst things, when you come
and everyone is doing whatever they want, you're not ready right now to go back.
I'm a senior this year and I just, I love school. So I really,
really want to go back.
But I definitely don't want to go back at the risk of like spreading COVID.
I'm actually like really happy with my school's plans.
Cause we have like four options that if you don't feel comfortable going back to
school, you have the option to not go back to school.
I really do would want to go back to school.
But at the same time I have to commute to school.
Yeah. I agree with you, Charlie. I want to go back,
but I have to take three buses, public transportation.
I'm not for that right now. The hybrid schedule half will go in Monday, Tuesday,
the other half we'll go in Wednesday, Thursday.
Everyone's home Friday for me to plan is unacceptable because about the kids who
aren't going in, like, what do we do? I feel like right now online school,
is it being part of the solution?
It's almost just like a punishment for like the government not taking enough
steps. I live in Nebraska and we were like the last city out of the biggest,
like a hundred cities to like get a mask mandate.
They said we were going to go back. And then like a week before school started,
they like completely changed their mind,
which in my opinion was like a good thing to do.
Cause like our numbers are just like, keep going up.
The schools are acting like they know what's happening, but like deep down,
like it's like clear that they have no clue either. Yeah,
I totally agree.
Because the teacher's union is so strong where I'm from the teachers wanting to
stay home. It's overpowering. The students needs,
they gave us the first month off to prepare.
But then that only resulted in them throwing a fit.
He worked for the rest of your money.
You need to adapt the medium and serve your students. I don't care.
That happens. I do agree with that at the same time,
that teaches all also an enormous amount of stress.
I definitely want to go back,
but I haven't seen firsthand how China dealt with it.
It's like coming back to the U S infection rate is incredibly high.
Having tested a fifth of the people to me, it's too steady.
And if every single kid went back to school,
I have missed out on major life milestones because of the pandemic
three, two, one
the summer after your junior year,
before your senior year is the one that's most important that colleges are going
to look at. I've tried so hard to like get a job or volunteer. I can't,
it's so frustrating.
Cause I track and gymnastics and like captains on both those teams super,
super excited to be a captain just like really turned everything upside
down. It kind of sucks.
I moved from my country about three years ago.
I was a lot of stuff behind everyone else.
I literally learned about college application. Last year,
this year I was going to do all those things that people started doing freshman
year, but because of the pandemic was everything got canceled.
And I was very sad. I felt like I was even more step behind everyone else.
Or where you're from.
I'm from Venezuela.
I was.
Well for me when I was leaving there,
the lie would just not work nor water or not good internet connection.
And they are doing, um, only school. So it is a mess, but I'm glad I'm.
Yeah. First of all, you're so brave for like leaving your country.
I'm a first generation and my family had to go through something similar to you.
You're the best. So the main thing I missed out on was the musical,
which was crushing because I've been wanting to be in it since first grade.
Once I actually thought about it, I was actually kind of miserable at school.
Um, I was always the black sheep of migraines. So to not get weird.
Stares is like, Oh my God, I'm actually a person who matters.
It's actually been quite good for my mental health.
I have experienced mental health issues due to the pandemic
three, two, one.
This pandemic was extremely damaging to my mental health
on so many different levels.
And black lives matter movement was like hitting headlines again. Um,
because of the death of George Floyd,
it was very uncomfortable for me because I had people like DM-ing me personally,
like questions, Oh gosh, it makes me cringe. What can I do?
How can I be a better person? I don't understand what's going on.
And I was like, I understand that because you know,
some people just don't truly know what's going on in the world.
But being like the little girl I am like,
I didn't know how to explain to people why my life matters.
And then not to mention with my school, I was asked like,
how do we help make our students of color more comfortable? I was just like,
shouldn't I already be comfortable. Like,
I feel like it should be a space for everyone.
You shouldn't have to like accommodate to me. And then that moment,
like I realized that some people who claim to be my friends warrant, they saw,
um, the black lives matter movement more as like a trend. So I was like,
kind of telling everyone, please just give me some space.
I'm really overwhelmed. I don't know how to process this. Like as teenagers,
like I feel like we shouldn't have to have like a care in the world,
but it almost feels as if so much stuff has been like shoved at us that it's
like, we don't know how to deal with this.
And it feels like we have to deal with this like way sooner than we should like
have to deal with it.
My country is basically a bubble.
You don't realize you are in that bubble until you get out of that.
They are worried for other things that thankfully we don't have to worry about
like if you're safe or if you were
going to eat something tomorrow. So when I came here,
I realized he knew years have more time and more
rights and platforms to voice what they want to say.
And a lot of people are watching them and listen to them while in my
country just cannot do that.
Yeah.
And that's why I feel like this quarantine is maybe taking us out of that and
sort of opening our eyes like 20, 20, 20, 20 vision.
Like that's what I think of.
We're sort of realizing that we aren't going to like stick through
with this system and we really need to be like living our lives. At some point,
I think the us is handling the pandemic properly.
Three, two, one,
no, not at all.
The government failed their class. You should be kicked out of the classroom.
Like we need a refresher here.
Our state is practically just a cornfield.
People think that like the world doesn't like reach us exactly a
week ago, a mask mandate.
Like finally in my city, it's not being enforced like at all,
like our own like governor is against it now more than ever like
change needs to happen.
And that change can happen November 3rd, everybody go out.
Yeah. They basically did everything that they could wrong.
First after that the politician decide what, uh,
motion should we pass and what should it be?
And then they let it go down to the local and state levels.
So you can't make a uniform decision. And the,
at least the people themselves who were like, no, what my light is,
I don't have to wear a mask. So I'm not going to wear it.
And then for people in China, my feds were like,
what in the world are they thinking? Are they out of their minds?
And for them to say, this is, this is the pinnacle of a Medicaid,
like from the outside bullet, this is America at its best. They, okay.
It's worse.
I noticed that we're holding Australia on New Zealand on such a pedestal.
However,
I get a little fishy because they have crazy curfews and they're installing
cameras to track their citizens.
Like it's extremely important to protect people,
but like the people will question things. They do have a point,
like how much of our personal freedom are we going to sacrifice for this virus?
What rights am I willing to have stripped away throughout history when rights
are taken away, they don't typically come back. I mean,
you can pack the social distancing 110%. Correct. And have all of you, like,
you can still talk on social media, right? Like,
no nobody's picked lodged gatherings. Well, dude, it's a pandemic. I mean,
it's sorta like, that's exactly what you're not supposed to do.
I think levels to it though.
I think it's very fair that like there are certain levels and degrees into
which it's like, Oh,
well that's like a little aggressive.
One of the reasons why America has struggled so much with mandates and
everything is that people believe so strongly in the idea of personal freedom.
They don't understand that in order to have personal freedom.
And in order to live in a society, you have to give up other things.
The pandemic has affected my future plans. Three,
two, one.
Before when I was younger, I was like,
I'm going to go to USC film school and I'm going to become a film director.
And I was just like, that's my goal,
but I don't really know how what's going to happen after high school,
but I'm also have faith that whatever happens I'll be happy with.
And then I just found out recently that like USC is handing out free tuition.
And I actually may have an opportunity if I get in to pursue that.
I have no clue what I want to do with my life,
which is so hard for me because growing up, like I wanted to be a singer.
I want to be an edge just because I wanted to be a criminal justice defense
attorney. I have no clue where I want to go.
But I do believe in me and is manifest manifestation,
manifesting, I believe in manifestation.
So if I know that I'm going to end up good.
I'm going to look at that. I'm going to be great.
It's just that I don't know what I'm going to be great in it.
And I'm okay with it. I'm okay.
Snaps for that. Very well said very well said.
That is it for our conversation. Thank you guys. Good.
It was so nice talking to you all.
Should we all chat like our Instagram handles? Yes. That
is so long. You can change it, you know? Oh, wait.